-Thank you.
Welcome back to the show.
I just want to say,
happy birthday to you --
right now --
-Thank you!
-Right now, it's your birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is your birthday.
-It is.
It is my golden birthday.
It's my 19th birthday
on the 19th.
-This only happens
once in your lifetime.
-I know!
-This is fantastic.
Happy golden birthday!
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear JoJo ♪
Golden!
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Hey, fantastic!
They can sing!
[ Cheers and applause ]
They can sing.
-I got to say,
hearing "Happy Birthday"
on "The Tonight Show" for me
is probably the coolest thing
I've ever heard in my life.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Wow!
-Happy, happy, happy.
Do you --
Do you celebrate your birthdays?
'Cause I know you go big
on others --
-Oh, yeah.
-You do.
-Oh yeah.
-Really?
-We go full out.
-You do?
-On everything we go full out.
But, so here's the thing.
My birthday's today,
and my brother's birthday
is tomorrow, actually.
-Wow.
-So our whole lives,
we would always do,
like, a 50/50 party.
And we'd literally, like,
draw a line of tape in our house
and half would be my side
and half would be his side.
And then, my 13th birthday
was my first big, like,
birthday blowout bash.
And since then, you know,
my 14th birthday,
we were actually in a tornado
shelter in a Walmart.
-Wow.
-Then my 15th birthday,
we rented out Dave & Busters.
16th birthday,
we rented out Six Flags.
17th birthday was quarantine.
18th birthday was Disney World.
And 19th birthday
was "The Tonight Show"!
-That's exactly how you do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now.
-This is the best one.
-That's how you do it.
-This is the best one, for sure.
-I'm wishing you the best.
We're sending you the vibes.
-Thank you.
-You're gonna have
the best year ever.
You -- at 19, you've already
accomplished so much.
You're one of Time's 100
Most Influential People.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Boomerang" has almost
1 billion views on YouTube.
-Wild.
-A billion.
-A billion. And it just had its
six-year anniversary, too.
-Isn't that wild?
-It's crazy to think about.
-One billion views.
-And it still gets about
500,000 views a day.
-Wow.
-Which is wild to think about.
And like, little kids now,
who are 2 years old,
their favorite song
is "Boomerang."
And for me, I'm like, "How?
They weren't even alive
when it came out."
It's wild.
-Wow.
It just lives on.
But there's -- there's one thing
that you haven't done yet,
and it involves Lady Gaga.
-Oh, yes.
-Explain this to me.
-So, my, like, dream
is to either, like,
play Lady Gaga in a biopic
of her life one day.
-Uh-huh.
-Now, if that doesn't happen,
my next dream is to just be
a backup dancer for her --
for one day.
-Well, I mean, you --
-One day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can do it. I mean --
-Thank you.
We actually -- we have the same
choreographer, Richy Jackson,
who is amazing.
And I -- I tell him
all the time, because I know
about 20, 25 Lady Gaga dances
that she does at her concerts.
And I tell Richy all the time,
I'm like, "Listen, one day,
a dancer's gonna be sick,
they're not gonna be on stage,
you're gonna have one hour
to find someone
who knows the whole set,
and you're gonna call me,
and I'm gonna be prepared."
And I -- I'm banking on that
happening one day.
-I mean -- Lady Gaga watches
the show all the time.
Gaga...
-Gaga...
-Hello, come on, let's go.
This is it, right now.
-Gaga.
-A dream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't stop a dream.
-One day.
It can be a press stunt --
for me.
-Yeah.
Whatever, whoever you want it
to be, yeah.
We've got to do it.
I would love to see you.
Come on.
-Hey, Gaga, Jimmy said --
-She's -- I mean, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She's touring now, right?
Is Gaga doing --
-Yeah, "Chromatica Ball"
is just about to start.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It's happening.
All right,
I'm gonna vibe this out.
This is the golden birthday.
Come on.
If we all send the vibes,
it's gonna happen.
-Right! You would think,
you would think.
-All right, good, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to talk to you about
"So You Think You Can Dance."
-Yes.
-Season 17 premiered last night.
You are a judge.
-Yes, yes.
-I -- how -- You've been a fan
of the show, must have been,
since you were a baby.
-Yeah, since I --
I mean, the show came out,
I think,
the year after I was born.
So it's been around
literally my whole life.
-Literally when you were a baby,
yeah.
-Yeah, which is -- it --
it's crazy to think about.
I remember going to
the tour of the show, actually,
when I was like 5,
and I did the meet-and-greet
with the cast of that season --
I think it was season nine
maybe at the time.
And it was -- No,
it definitely wasn't season 9.
It was season 5.
'Cause my friend
was on season -- anyways,
back at it -- it was season 5.
And it -- it's just so cool
to think that this show
is such an iconic piece
of the dance world
and of dance history.
And every dancer
that has such a household name
was born on this show,
if that makes sense.
-Yeah.
-They were first seen
on this show, and it gives
dancers such a platform.
And so, to be part of it
in this way, just --
It means the world to me.
-Do they --
Do they get nervous when they go
out and dance in front of you?
-Oh, my God, they're terrified.
-Yeah, of course.
-They're terrified.
And it's -- it's funny to watch,
because being on the judges
side of the things --
You know, I had
"Dancing With the Stars,"
where I was competing.
I competed on "Masked Singer."
I was
"Ultimate Dance Competition."
I've had my fair share
of elimination shows.
And to be on this side of it,
be judging,
it's interesting to watch.
It's like "They're nervous,
but I'm not, so why are they?"
But then I'm like,
"No, okay, now I --"
-"I've been on the other side,"
yeah, where you were nervous,
and, yeah, and being judged.
-Yeah.
They are so talented, though,
it's insane.
-How do you --
How are you as a judge?
-How do you think I am?
-I would say that you're --
I would say that you're --
You give positive --
I think you're always positive
when I'm around you,
so I would say you probably
give positive feedback.
I mean, I don't know
if I could do it,
because I'd be like --
"I don't know."
I would be like,
"I don't -- pass."
-I'll admit I'm --
[ Laughter ]
-"Go talk to someone else.
Talk to another judge."
-"Next, next."
-Yeah, yeah, I can't do it.
-I will admit,
I am the honest judge.
So, if something is great,
I can't hold back,
I will tell you.
-Yep.
-If something is not,
I will also not hold back,
and I will tell you.
So it can be a problem
sometimes.
But I just --
I want the people who are good
to know that I am dead serious
when they are good.
You know what I mean?
I don't just want
to tell everyone
that they're great, if...
-Yeah, of course.
-...you know, they're not.
-Yeah. You go,
"Hey, you got to work --"
-I don't know.
-"You got to work harder."
-I'm naturally
just an honest person.
-Yeah.
-All the time.
-I think that people would
rather hear that, though,
and go, like, "Hey, come back."
-Yeah.
-"Go work on this.
You have something,
if you want to do this."
-Exactly.
Exactly.
That's what we tell people.
We say, "Go, and come back,
and keep working."
Because everybody who gets
to this point is incredible.
-Yeah, and if you hear something
from JoJo Siwa, to give you
even any advice, or any help,
you'll never forget that
as long as you live.
-Yes.
-You'll go,
"Yeah, she told me to do that,
and I'm gonna do that."
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's the birthday girl,
JoJo Siwa in
"So You Think You Can Dance."
Take a look at this.
-Out of everyone
that I've seen today,
you had the most fun
on this stage.
And that is something
that I really appreciate.
-Thank you.
-I love that you are
who you are.
I love that you're out here in
heels and your little shorts.
I'm...
-You know it.
-...a hundred --
My best --
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Listen.
I am very gay, too.
So I --
Yes, whatever you do, you do.
Not my type.
But my --
-Don't worry.
You're not mine, either.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He was amazing.
-Nailed it. That's good.
-That was Beau. He's great.
-He's great?
JoJo Siwa, everybody.
"So You Think You Can Dance"
airs Wednesday nights
at 9:00 p.m. on Fox.